bonjour bienvenue dans ses cages c'est
une émission que vous pouvez regarder
sans remplir d'attestation
bonjour aujourd'hui nous allons vous
parler de l'union européenne face aux
coronavirus bonjour et celle bonjour
olivier bonjour a tous rêvé de vous
retrouver pour ce nouveau numéro de ses
caches il ya un peu plus d'un an le
coronavirus est déferlait sur les pays
européens avec les premiers signalements
de cas de kovy de 19 en europe en
janvier 2020 en mars 2020 l'europe
faisait face au confinement et ses
difficultés économiques qui vont avec
alors un an après où en es l'union
européenne comment se porte l'économie
quelle leçon pour la zone euro ce sont
les questions au coeur de cette émission
à cette semaine et pour en parler nous
serons en deuxième partie avec bernard
mono économiste et ancien député
européen
mais d'abord je vous le disais cela fait
plus d'un an que l'union européenne fait
face à la pandémie de coronavirus en une
année près de 600 mille victimes du coc
u19 ont été recensés sur les territoires
européens
s'ajoutent à cela des restrictions
sanitaires d économie en berne et des
difficultés parfois pour les membres de
lieu à se coordonner
retour sur cette année succo vide avec
le tiroir cash d'antoine passe en un an
du coup vides il y en a eu des épisodes
avec l'union européenne
arrêtons-nous sur trois en particulier
en mars 2020 d'italie premier pays
européen touché appel à l'aide face à la
pandémie
pas de réponse et c'est finalement des
pays extérieurs qu'ils apportent de
l'aide
le signe d'un manque de solidarité entre
les états de l'ue eux
heureusement ursula von der leyen finira
par s'excuser au nom de l'union lors des
premiers mois de la pandémie c'était un
peu chacun pour soi mais ça a évolué
avec le plan de relance européen 750
milliards d'euros qui a été décidé en
commun même s'il a été quelques temps
bloqué par le veto de
plusieurs pays qui ne venaient pas
rendre de comptes sur leur politique
intérieure ou sur la manière de dépenser
leur partie du plan de relance
finalement la situation avec les
frondeurs s'est débloqué le plan de
relance n'est pas encore ratifié par
tous les états membres
c'est christine lagarde qui a dit il y a
quelques jours demandant aux états de
passer à l'action plus vite
dernier épisode en date celui du vaccin
astrazeneca certains pays suspende son
utilisation
d'autres non puis finalement sig a en
fait non lui a un peu de mal à se mettre
d'accord
elle se retrouve également à menacer
d'une seule voix de bloquer les
exportations de vaccins
déplorant le retard d'astrazeneca dans
ses livraisons
il faut dire que des vaccins produits
sur le sol européen se retrouvent
envoyées à d'autres pays
alors que les pays membres en ont
cruellement besoin et surtout qu'il y a
un contrat avec le labo pharmaceutique
même si sur cette année de kovy duo n'a
pas toujours été parfaite elle c'est
avec ces derniers épisodes montré bien
plus soudé qu'au début de la pandémie et
on vient de le voir lui n'a essuyé
quelques ratés pendant cette année à de
pandémie alors évidemment il est trop
tôt pour tirer un bilan de cette crise
sanitaire
mais quelle première leçon lieu
doit-elle à tirer de cette crise selon
vous moi qu'il est urgent que concas
cette machine infernale dans le tiroir
catch il ya eu quelques ratés lieu
ça n'était pas exhaustif vous avez aussi
l'achat je vous appelle du remdh et y
virent aura milliards et on ne sait pas
ce qu'on va en faire puisqu'on s'est
aperçu que c'était un médicament qui ne
marchaient pas donc qu'ils étaient
toxiques
donc on a un stock
qui valait 1 milliard a été acheté par
l'union européenne et il a aussi à
dépenser ça pour rien donc non on a vu
simplement que ce qui était ce qui était
attendu on a vu simplement que quand les
problèmes arrivent c'est chacun pour soi
c'est à dire que l'allemagne joue sa
carte sans s'occuper de ce qui se passe
ailleurs et que le l'union européenne et
le couple le soi-disant couple franco
allemand fait chambre à part depuis
longtemps c'est tout donc on voit qu'à
chaque fois qu'on essaie de faire un
plan de relance
bon qui est mal ficelé depuis le départ
puisque on voulait dit ici plusieurs
fois c'est un plan dans lequel nous
versons plus que ce que nous recevons
donc je vois pas très bien l'intérêt de
faire ce genre de choses donc on voit
très bien que ça coince parce que vous
avez des pays qui sont pas d'accord à ce
moment là on essaie de leur imposer les
choses
donc ça c'est dans le le jeu
démocratique de l'europe
on voit que ça ne fonctionne pas c'est
tout simple donc mais ça ne fonctionnait
pas avant c'est pas juste le que vie qui
a fait que ça ne fonctionnait pas c'est
simplement que le coc vie d'amy encore
des choses en évidence par rapport à
quelque chose qui est là depuis le début
donc voila mais sanaa c'est un
révélateur le coc vide on l'a dit
plusieurs fois c'est un révélateur
économique c'est un accélérateur aussi
mais c'est ça n'est en aucun cas le
problème
merci olivier tout de suite la deuxième
partie de cette émission
et cette semaine nous sommes en liaison
avec bernard mono bonjour monsieur vous
êtes économiste politique vous avez été
député européen entre 2014 et 2019 et
vous êtes aussi proche de debout la
france merci beaucoup d'être parmi nous
bien venez danser cash
bonjour bernard mono on s'est intéressé
en première partie notamment avec le
tiroir cash sur les ratés de l'union
européenne durant cette année sous
qu'ovide pour autant mais y at il des
points positifs des points sur lequel
l'est sur lesquelles l'action européenne
a été une réussite selon ona beau aucun
pour avoir participé pendant cinq ans
lors d'une mandature à la vie
institutionnelle de l'union européenne
au sein du parlement européen
c'est une institution supranationale qui
me sert strictement à rien qui c'est une
usine à gaz qui complique la vie des
nations européennes qui d'ailleurs
europe qui existait avant l'union
européenne et qui existera après l'union
européenne donc en un mot non alors
olivier locaux vides serait certainement
vaincu mais il risque avant d'être
défait d'avoir fait une victime
collatérale le projet européen ce sont
les mots du politologue dominique mot
ici dans les échos le elle a pourtant
connu de nombreuses crises a eu 2008
avec la crise économique 2015 avec la
crise de la migratoires il ya eu le
break cite aussi pourquoi la crise
ducobu de 19 serait telle celle qui en
quelque sorte pourrait donner le coup de
grâce a lieu parce que c'est un
accélérateur c'est tout c'est à dire que
vous êtes vous êtes sur une une crise
qui n'a qui n'a en fait jamais été
résolu ce c'était la crise de 2008 mais
vous avez un montage initial qui est
mauvais donc le montage initial tant que
tout va bien et bien
ça ça passe on va dire et puis à
l'occasion d'une première crise on
s'aperçoit qu'il ya certains
dysfonctionnements et l'édifice commença
à branler et puis et puis au fil des de
la succession de crises qu'il ya eu
depuis depuis 2008 donc au vide et la
dernière manifestation mais ça n'est en
rien je vous ai dit la cause des deux de
2,7 de cette crise économique qui en
fait est une crise économique qui dure
depuis 2008 et qui n'a jamais été résolu
la poussière ressort de deux sous le
tapis et vous avez vous avez des dégâts
collatéraux qui sont que l'aîné fils
branle de plus en plus c'est va finir
par tomber c'est tout à chaque fois on a
une preuve de plus que cette institution
ne fonctionne pas qu'elle ne sert à rien
qu'elle coûte extrêmement cher et que
donc je vois pas bien l'intérêt de la
garder en plus c'est une cc
supranationales comme le disait bernard
c'est supranationale ça veut dire que
les gens qui sont là bas ne sont pas des
élus la commission européenne c'est pas
des élus donc vous ne pouvez pas les
virées même s'ils font les pires bêtises
donc c'est antidémocratique en plus donc
déjà on a un gros déficit de démocratie
depuis quelque temps
dans les pays lui il faut pas en
rajouter avec une institution supra
national olivier sur le volet économique
à présent qu est ce qui ressort
concrètement de l'action européenne
qu'est ce que vous retiendrez de
l'action européenne
c'est ce que je sais ce que je vous ai
dit au départ c'est à dire vous avez au
lieu d'aller directement soit négocié
avec des laboratoires soient directement
emprunté sur le sur le marché pour faire
un plan de relance emprunté 40 milliards
c'est ce qu'on va recevoir de l'union
européenne mais sans avoir besoin de fil
et 80 milliards à l'union européenne
donc pas je vois pas bien l'intérêt si
vous voulez dans quand vous êtes quand
vous cherchez à faire un plan de relance
et qu'il faut passer par l'europe et
qu'au final ça va vous coûter 80
milliards de plus que ce que vous
recevez j'ai je comprends pas
christine lagarde a tapé du poing sur la
table 18 mars a appelé les états membres
de lieu à ratifier sans délai le plan de
relance européen donc de 750 milliards
d'euros on l'a dit
car à l'heure où on parle il n'est
toujours pas ratifié il a pourtant été
adopté par les 27 alors il ya eu entre
autant aller veto et de la pologne de la
hongrie que l es deux pays ont fini par
lever alors est ce que cette lenteur
alors que les pays font face à des
crises économiques ne vient pas à
nouveau donner un peu plus de grain à
moudre à ceux qui pointent du doigt un
certain manque de coordination au sein
du lieu oui absolument
en fait comme le dit monsieur de la
marche
quelle est la valeur ajoutée de l'union
européenne dans toutes ces négociations
entre 27 pays si vous voulez européen
aucune
on voit que c'est extrêmement compliqué
et que au passage dans le si on parle du
calcul ce d'auckland relance européen on
s'aperçoit que pour la france c'est un
coup d'état de la commission européenne
sur le budget de la france et donc c'est
là que
il a été dit que ça a été historique ce
qui a été historique c'est que nous
avons perdu un peu plus de pouvoirs
budgétaires au profit la commission
européenne qui va faire des émissions de
dette donc pour pour avoir 750 milliards
de plans de relance mais la france n'a
pas besoin de se refinancer auprès de la
commission européenne
elle existait avant auparavant nous
avions la banque de france pendant
cinquante ans nous avons fait sans
l'union européenne et la commission
européenne et donc on peut faire mieux
plus vite et plus simplement en passant
directement par la france pas
éventuellement la banque centrale
européenne c'est ce qui est c'est le cas
depuis 2015 avec un financement des
politiques monétaires c'est ce qu'avait
fait monsieur draghi
et puis 2015 avec le plan de soutien de
l'économie des économies de l'union fin
de l'euro mais on pourrait très bien le
faire au niveau national sans passer par
la case bruxelles mais si on va marquer
une courte pause en revient dans un
instant
et cette semaine pour parler de l'union
européenne nous sommes en liaison avec
bernard mono économistes politiques et
ancien député européen bernard mono ont
parlé du plan de relance européen juste
avant la coupure
ce plan de relance il prévoit notamment
une mutualisation des têtes des dettes
des pays membres de l'union européenne
c'est du jamais vu au sein l'union cette
mutualisation est ce que l'on peut
traduire cette initiative comme par
exemple une leçon retenue en quelque
sorte par l'union européenne
c'est-à-dire finit un peu le chacun pour
soi
oui m'enfin c'est quoi la finalité c'est
quoi l'objectif
l'objectif c'est d'avoir des économies
qu'ils soient réels qui soit stable et
qu'ils soient prospères et on s'aperçoit
que depuis l'existence de l'union
européenne ça va ça va faire bientôt 30
ans c'est-à-dire maastricht 92
et bien tout ce qu'on vous a vendue
c'est à dire le plein emploi la
prospérité les équilibres budgétaires
etc
c'est tout l'inversé qui s'est produit
et donc c'est le triste bilan que l'on
peut faire aujourd'hui
olivier une réaction à ces propos de
l'économiste jean pisani-ferry mme dans
les échos il parle de l'union européenne
je cite une percée économique
un fiasco sanitaires à l'heure d'un
premier bilan certainement trop précoce
c'est ce qui ressort de l'action
européenne face à la pandémie
si vous êtes d'accord avec cela olivier
j'ai pas compris perd ses économies et
scénique fiasco sanitaires oui c'est un
vaste percée oui
il ya une grosse fuite économique
non feinte aujourd'hui on regarde les
les pays et on s'aperçoit que l'europe
est encore une fois à la traîne
économiquement donc d'où là quel intérêt
je vous dis de deux d'avoir cette cette
commission européenne et en plus pour
revenir sur le plan de relance le fameux
plan de relance et sur la mutualisation
de la dette
il ya une contrepartie en plus c'est à
dire qu'on paye plus qu'on ne reçoit
beaucoup plus qu'on ne reçoit mais en
plus il ya des contreparties c'est à
dire que en effet le la commission
européenne met la main sur notre budget
et est aujourd'hui contrôle encore plus
c'est à dire va faire va donner des
instructions qu'il faudra suivre
en échange de ces de cette distribution
d'argent à l'envers puisque je vous dis
on paye plus que qu'on ne reçoit donc il
ya réellement enfin on va finir tous
au final avec une espèce de troïka qui
gouvernera et
monsieur mac on sera là pour signer les
ordonnances corps a pris précédemment la
commission européenne on va revenir sur
la gestion de la crise
bernard mono on a souvent parlé du
manque de coordination de l'union
européenne pour autant elle a par
exemple sur ce qui se passe avec
astrazeneca
l'union européenne est en train de
parler d'une seule et même voix est ce
que là aussi on peut y voir en quelque
sorte une leçon tirer de ce qui s'est
passé précédemment comme vous dites ils
parlent ils communiquent ils font des
déclarations vous voyez mesdames an der
leyen prendre la parole dans des
conférences de précédents mais ce sont
que des intentions
au final on s'aperçoit que c'est
extrêmement long et extrêmement cher qui
n'ont finalement pas de pouvoir
contrairement à ce qu ils veulent
laisser entendre et que un pays
déterminé comme l'intro bien négocier
directement avec les laboratoires
et puis voir faire de la recherche
fondamentale pour avec l'institut
pasteur où nos laboratoires français
sanofi synthélabo pour développer nous
mêmes nos propres nos propres vrai mac
simple sur la vaccination
l'union européenne a aussi décidé d'agir
les états membres ont aussi décidé
d'agir ensemble les pays ne ne
fonctionne pas ensemble et ça c'est une
c'est une réalité ils l'ont jamais fait
valider les pays ne fonctionnent pas
ensemble mais sur sûr être examinée qu'à
ils ont décidé de bloquer l'exportation
ensemble bloqué l'exportation
mais au départ ils ont ils ont
interrompu la vaccination pour rappel et
chacun unilatéralement sans se concerter
à est donc enfin il n'y a aucune
cohérence
il ya des ja en effet des paroles mais
il n'y a aucune cohérence
monsieur amon au vu de la façon dont
s'est déroulée se déroule toujours la
crise sanitaire
quels mécanismes quelle structure
l'union européenne pourrait elle mettre
sur pied pour répondre éventuellement la
prochaine crise je pense qu'il faudrait
encore une sans rien attendre de l'union
européenne il faut que chaque pays
indépendant prenne son destin en main y
compris la sécurité sanitaire ce qui est
un devoir je crois c'est même le premier
devoir constitutionnel c'est d'assurer
la sécurité de ses citoyens au niveau la
constitution française donc déjà se
prendre en charge soi même on a
l'exemple du royaume uni on a l'exemple
d'israël
ils l'ont fait ils ont réussi ils sont
en train de réussir pour le royaume uni
et donc après qu'ils aient une
coordination internationale entre le
royaume uni entre la france l'allemagne
l'italie etc et les 27 pays de l'union
européenne
pourquoi pas mais attendent une valeur
ajoutée de deux techniciens non élu à la
commission européenne
ça ne mène à rien ou le voit sur tous
les sujets on en a parlé un petit peu
avant économiques fiscaux c'est un échec
et un fiasco dans tous les domaines donc
moi je pense que il faut qu'on passe à
cette europe des patries qui coopèrent
ensemble est effectivement qu'ils
fassent bloc par rapport aussi aux
autres intérêts mondiaux que sont la
chine que sont les états unis et c'est
là que moi je propose dans mon projet
européen d'y inclure même la russie
puisque la russie a vocation à faire
partie
culturellement et civilisationnel mans
de l'europe un au sens large et et que
deux langues
comment dire de l'atlantique au
pacifique ce bloc là et du poids sur
l'ensemble des grandes décisions
mondiales notamment la spécialité merci
beaucoup bernard mono d'avoir participé
à cette émission je rappelle que vous
êtes économiste politique ancien député
européen il vous est aussi l'auteur de
l'essai l'eurovision pour les peuples le
patriotisme ou la banqueroute merci
beaucoup olivier pour vous c'est l'heure
des questions cash
et on commence à olivier avec la
question de xanthane une chose que je ne
comprends pas pourquoi les pays
occidentaux délocalisent tout en chine
alors qu'ils sont en concurrence et
s'inflige des sanctions pour faire de
l'argent rapidement ce jour la même
chose c'est-à-dire que vous avez une
entreprise qui délocalise pourquoi parce
que les coûts en chine et étaient bien
inférieurs et ça lui permettait de faire
des marges plus importantes
même en comptant le coup de rapatriement
sur sur le pays
vous aviez des coûts qui était
intéressant tout simplement parce qu'un
salarié chinois ça coûte le dixième d'un
salarié européen donc évidemment c'est
intéressant pour les entreprises
maintenant les sanctions et les sont
arrivés parce que il ya eu un monsieur
qui s'appelait trump et qui a décidé de
taper du poing sur la table mais et
là aujourd'hui nous avons monsieur biden
qui probablement va être un petit peu
plus lâche sur la question donc voilà on
est on est dans lla un temps politique
un temps de l'entreprise c'est pas les
mêmes et ça explique pourquoi tout d'un
coup vous avez un noeud ce genre de
questions où vous dites ça sert à quoi
d'aller délocaliser si c'est pour se
prendre des sanctions
d'abord parce que ça s'est pas fait au
même moment c'est tout allez on passe à
la question de josé comment à cette
honte les statistiques chinoises sont
fausses
bon c'est parce qu'il ya plusieurs il ya
plusieurs choses qu'on a fait depuis
depuis déjà un moment ça et qu'on
surveillait par exemple tout ce qui
était production et consommation
électrique parce que quand vous faites
7% de croissance pas forcément vous
utiliser plus d'énergie vous utilisez
plus d'électricité et curieusement on
s'est aperçu que tout d'un coup il y
avait une baisse de la consommation
électrique
et puis on vous annonce et d'autre part
7 ou 8% de croissance donc on s'est dit
ça colle pas ensuite on garder les
chiffres publiés au niveau de leurs
exportations et puis curieusement quand
on prenait les importations des pays
dans lesquels ils exportaient bas on
n'avait pas les mêmes chiffres on avait
même des chiffres qui est situé souvent
autour de la moitié donc on se disait ah
bah tiens il ya de la marchandise qui
est qui a coulé très probablement en
trajets en tout cas n'est pas arrivé
donc
et puis vous avez plein d'autres
indicateurs mais évidemment faut pas
choisir des indicateurs qu'il vous donne
et et il faut aller chercher un peu
creusé un peu on a regardé aussi tout ce
qu'ils étaient les derniers kilomètres
c'est à dire les camions de livraison
qui rentre et qui sortent des villes sur
les derniers kilomètres
et là on s'est aperçu qu'il y avait une
baisse importante de l'activité on garde
aussi le fret ferroviaire et à ce moment
là on s'aperçoit aussi qui a des dd des
chiffres qui ne sont pas cohérents alors
c'est très difficile de vous donner le
bon chiffre parce que parce que
justement on n'a pas toutes les
statistiques mais on sait que
probablement le chiffre qu'ils annoncent
peut être divisé de moitié à peu près
donc quand il vous dit 6% croissance
vous êtes probablement plutôt à 3 merci
beaucoup olivier c'est la fin de cette
émission merci de l'avoir suivi prochain
rendez vous la semaine prochaine en
attendant vous pouvez poser toutes vos
questions à olivier sur les réseaux
sociaux avec le hashtag rta cash olivier
inscrits avec votre dernier mot on a
trouvé rapidement un vaccin contre le
coc vide va-t-on trouver un jour un
vaccin qui nous vaccinera définitivement
contre l'union européenne